on termine avec à 1 mercredi très
spécial à montreuil où les enfants
étaient les rois cet après midi le salon
du livre de la jeunesse il ya ouvert ses
portes aujourd'hui et il a été bien sûr
envahi par les enfants si l'édition est
en crise en ce moment la littérature
pour les jeunes marche bien on
s'aperçoit que les enfants lisent
d'ailleurs de plus en plus et certains
éditeurs n'hésitent pas à créer un
département jeunesse reportage dans ce
salon de jean jacques blazy et jean marc
garde ils sont arrivés très tôt on fait
un petit tour de salon puis se sont
installés par terre livre à la main
oubliant complètement téléviseur the
video parfois même ce qu'il se passait
autour d'eux le chapiteau de montreuil
se transforme en une grande une très
grande bibliothèque pour enfants des
romans c'est tout cendrillon la belle et
la bête tout comme ça les ventes des
petites bandes dessinées sur la
télévision ou lire et pourquoi ils
savent l'ironie of sur la télé un cri
wine forward ça ils connaissent un mets
mais je crois qu'ils sont lui il faut
pas s'affoler et puis moi je connais
plein de garçons et de filles qui sont
en bonne santé qui disent presque pas
qui font du vélo qui font autre chose
et puis un jour il tombe le tombe dans
un livre il ya un
un déclencheur formidable et c'est gagné
contrairement à une idée reçue les
enfants lisent de plus en plus les
éditeurs rivalisent d'imagination et
même ceux qui jusqu'à là n'avaient pas
développer ce secteur silence à
commencer par la prestigieuse maison du
seuil après 55 ans d'existence a l'âge
d'être grand mère elle s'intéresse aux
enfants est présente pour la première
fois 30 nouveautés colorées et
originales
c'est toujours les sols de récession
qu'on arrive à créer des choses
originales et qui vous marque et le
futur d'où tu viens
les éditions du seuil de sciences et un
moment où justement père et de la
frilosité pour la première fois en dix
ans l'édition jeunesse connaît une
légère baisse
rien d'alarmant pour l'instant elle
continue de diffuser six millions
d'exemplaires par mois
voilà le salon du livre de la jeunesse
et donc toute la semaine à montreuil